ciao ho visto il sito mclean a quello
rosso e vorrei provarlo che bello questo
maglione prova anche questo provate
questa maglia questa è gente questo top
ed anche questi nick stesse grazie a chi
guarda tutto molto bello è rivestito in
particolare mi sta benissimo però molto
di fretta devo scappare qui magari passo
domani e dopo domani o mai più grazie
no no guarda solo guardando sentimmo la
m di quella che noi lo provo tanto sul
gioco mi sto roma risso come immaginavo
mi sto malissimo
sembra un involtino primavera
sentimmo invece quei jeans e almeno c'è
la mia taglio i verdi verdi ogni volta
che mi piace qualcosa non c'è ma la mia
taglio però se non con bus figata senti
a non farmi provare quella giacca non lo
so almeno una cosa me la voglio comprare
basta lo sapevo anche questa mi stava
rinuncio non è possibile che vado per
negozi nel tuo mai nulla che mi sta bene
invece la mia vita ogni volta mi si
compra un sacco di cose io mi metto gli
stessi vestiti da due anni no veramente
non ce la faccio più ma chi me lo fa
fare di andare in giro per negozi e
stressarmi a fare le code per pagare
code per provare questo caso tranquilla
sorseggiando il mio te e faccio shopping
online mou 300 euro ma forse esagerato
facciamo un po di selezione dai allora
questo quarto nando che tanto non
smettere mai di scarpe ne ho già tante e
questo pure non le fu anche questo è
niente allora dài teniamo questi quattro
via vado a pagamento con la banca ei
inserisco numero di telefono e confermo
basta affatto facile veloce sicuro e in
più cosa anche su fruire del cash back
bancomat dei cioè meglio di così non si
può
ciao vorrei provare uno di quei capacchi
che hanno la cintura in vita si doveva
ritiani rock e cammello per favore
allora nero un po un classico però
effettivamente lo avvenire con tutto
cammello che sta molto meglio come
colore però erano tutti e due non li
posso prendere sono gli avrei già prese
ovviamente mamma si chiama dato le foto
qualcosa di sci quello nero perché nero
mamma senti ma se mi comprarsi quello
nero che mi comprarsi quello cammello lo
so che sei in montagna andiamo a
inviarmi denaro tramite l'app bancomat
dei mama è facilissimo allora entri
nella selezione il contatto al quale
inviare denaro e cerato amantea
figlioletta di gt l'importo e poi
autorizzi invio del denaro è come sono
arrivati grazie manina li prendo tutti e
due ciao volevo provare quel maglione
nero ah che bello che quello di bianco
dai provo anche quello no vabbè quello
lì la bellezza dai proviamo questi tre
mi stanno tutti benissimo però prima
devo farmi delle domande mi servono
veramente tutti e tre no perché sono
piene di maglioni a casa quello bianco e
bellissimo però delicato e io sono una
sbadata cronica quindi lo sport che hai
subito eliminiamo quello nero lo
metterei sicuramente di più però ne ho
altri due neri metterli la non ho
neanche uno
e poi quelli di turchi renderebbe
veramente felice questo è come il bello
lo posso mettere quei jeans con il nero
con con tutti i comuni un uomo si prendo
questa ciao tesoro volevo quel vestito
rosa in tale small no tesoro non c'è
bisogno di provarlo cielo già in 14
colori ma che bello questo magari
natalizio che metterò soltanto una volta
nella vita prendo che questo apprendo
che questo cappotto massa impazza tesoro
non è per niente uguale a quello che
indossa fasti teatro e da un oculista
e prendo anche questi guanti sia lunghi
che costi grazie damian che gli stivali
oro gli anfibi neri puri ciabatte di
pelo fucsia e tutti i navy seal ecopelle
che ha in rosa rossi neri fai tu tutti
quanti tesoro pago con banco back bay
ovviamente fammi quadrare il quad core
perfetto e adesso conferma una
tradizione di 5.689 euro che poi come
diceva mia nonna che senso a lavorare se
poi non spendi soldi che guadagno ciao
scusa vorrei provare il vestito color in
vetrina quello nero
mamma mia che bello allora ti dico
provato è ancora più bello cioè sembra
che mi sia stato cucito addosso mi segna
proprio bene nei punti giusti
poi mi sta bene il colore no guarda io
sono innamorata potrei metto il premio
compreso tra qualche giorno lavora il
mio ragazzo impazzirò autolinee
699 euro
solo no ma perché pensavo di più per un
abito g
di questo tipo
senti ma e sei adesso che ci penso però
il resconto del mio compleanno in bianco
e bianco quindi è poi vero misfatti un
po sempre e vestiti di nero bastano è
però è così che arriva di un altro
colore che ne so prugna tu chiamami
chiamami perché ripasso 6 prende il
numero si
346 66 68 88 sia un posto è un po strano
il numero uno ma bello e ripasso grazie